ce chargement de bois d'okoumé quitte le
port d'owendo
au gabon le 3 mars 2009 à ce moment là
les employés des trois usines françaises
de plysorol
le numéro deux européen du contreplaqué
ne savent pas encore que leur entreprise
va mourir le bois est attendu à honfleur
en normandie il n'y arrivera jamais
bonjour je suis venu vous parler
d'intelligence économique
je vais en parler à partir de ma
pratique de mon expérience et de celle
de mes collègues qui s'en occupe
en basse-normandie l'intelligence
économique pour nous c'est une méthode
une méthode qui consiste à mettre
l'information au service d'une stratégie
d'un objectif l'intelligence économique
pour nous c'est l'information c'est le
traitement décisionnel de l'information
l'information traitée pour permettre de
prendre des décisions stratégiques
c'est le renseignement au service de la
compétitivité des entreprises
cette intelligence économique est mise
en oeuvre dans un monde notre monde qui
est un monde d'hyper compétition dans ce
monde là la performance des entreprises
la conquête des marchés peut servir
peuvent servir souvent la puissance des
états la volonté de puissance des
nations c'est le monde de la guerre
économique
bienvenue dans le monde réel
tel qu'il est le coup mais qui est
attendu à honfleur a été en fait
débarquer à shanghai
pendant ce temps en normandie en vendée
en champagne les machines de plysorol
sont à l'arrêt plysorol a été reprise
par un groupe chinois
un groupe qui s'est engagé à la barre du
tribunal de commerce à la moderniser
tout en conservant les emplois en
réalité son objectif n'est pas de
développer l'entreprise
son objectif c'est de mettre la main sur
une concession de 600 mille hectares de
coûts mais dont plysorol bénéficie au
gabon d'acheminer ce bois vers la chine
pour le transformer et de la le
transporter vers la france pour lui
faire subir une dernière transformation
superficielle un étiquetage et un
conditionnement de manière à pouvoir le
rpt est exporté à partir de la france
pour contourner l'embargo qui est mis
par l'europe et par les états unis sur
les contreplaqués chinois c'est une
stratégie bien organisé bien pensé un an
avant la mise en oeuvre de cette
stratégie
mes collègues et moi-même chargé de
l'intelligence économique en normandie
nous avions dévoilé ce plan
c'était déjà trop tard lorsqu'à la fin
de 2010 l'entreprise est enfin
soustraite à la rapacité de sans
repreneur chinois qui évidemment n'y a
jamais investi un euro
elle est exempte et elle disparaît
pendant tout ce temps les autorités
chinoises ont soutenu l'opération des
financements par des banques publiques
une campagne de presse en chine un
dénigrement systématique des cadres et
des syndicats français des pressions
incessantes sur les autorités gabonaises
des intimidations en france et même des
intimidations physiques au gabon c'est
cela la guerre économique des
entreprises qui disparaissent
après avoir perdu leur marché leur
capital leur savoir-faire leur
réputation des salariés qui perdent leur
emploi leurs illusions et l'espoir d'un
avenir
il ne suffit plus de produire ou de
faire un bon produit pour vendre il faut
savoir anticiper les coups tordus comme
celui que nous venons de voir et même
parfois apprendre à riposter ici la
riposte est venue trop tard
elle a été trop faible trop tard parce
que l'ambition de la chine de devenir l'
usine à bois de la planète
cette ambition n'avait pas été perçues
attend trop tard parce que les
conséquences de cette stratégie mise en
oeuvre par un état sur les entreprises
n'avaient pas été perçues n'avait pas
été anticipé trop faible parce que la
détermination la cohérence la rapidité
le génie de ceux qui ont mis en oeuvre
cette stratégie ont été terriblement
sous-estimé la mes collègues et moi nous
nous sommes dit plus jamais cela subir
plus j'aime bien riposter oui mais
surtout anticiper
il était temps un 2010 de se rendre
compte que l'on pouvait racheter une
entreprise non pas pour la développer
mais pour s'approprier son patrimoine
ses technologies voir ces concessions de
bois rares l'intelligence économique
commence par la veille c'est-à-dire
sélectionnés dans le flot des
informations qui nous arrive au risque
de l'infobésité celles qui sont
pertinentes celles qui ont un sens
les mettre en perspective pour pouvoir
agir l'intelligence économique
pour nous elle est orientée vers
l'action nous devions donc améliorer
notre veille pour qu'elle serve mieux à
l'action mais à peine le temps de se
retourner et une autre affaire éclate
après le crash test intervenu le 21 juin
le constructeur chinois geely doit
renoncer à faire homologuer son modèle
en europe
pendant ce temps
loin du bruit loin du monde dans une
vallée riante de l'orne
lusine d'emboutissage sofedit coule des
jours tranquilles au sein du puissant
groupe allemand thyssenkrupp en 2010
pourtant des salariés s'inquiètent ils
s'inquiètent en se rendant compte que
des visiteurs du soir sont invités à
découvrir discrètement lusine ma
collègue un ingénieur chargé
l'automobile m'apprend que le programme
d'investissement que l'état subventionné
subventions que nous avions mis en place
est interrompue suspendu lui dit le
directeur suspendu parce qu'une
réflexion stratégique est en cours
alertés par la convergence de ces
signaux faibles
je ne tarde pas à découvrir que les
syndicats allemands eux-mêmes s'émeuvent
de la vente par thyssen krupp de sa
division emboutissage dont notre usine
fait partie que s'est il passé
quel est le rapport entre le crash test
est ce que je viens de dire est bien la
chine n'est pas restée inerte
après le crash test l'automobile propre
et sûre est devenu une priorité
industrielle elle figurera en tant que
tel dans le xième plan chinois et cela a
été publié
c'est un document public et nous
l'avions vu trois brevets déposés par
sofedit concerne la sécurité de
l'habitacle des voitures ce qui permet
des arceaux qui permettent de consolider
l'habitacle et de résister au crash test
ce qui met la main dessus peuvent
réussir les crash tests imposés par la
réglementation européenne en juillet
2010 nous découvrons l'existence depuis
janvier de pourparlers confidentielles
entre thyssenkrupp et le groupe chinois
shougang
nous informons immédiatement les
constructeurs automobiles français
ils comprennent tout de suite le risque
nous les aidons à consolider l'offre de
rachat qui a été monté par un groupe
européen concurrent des chinois une
offre que finalement thyssen krupp devra
accepter
la protection du patrimoine c'est le
deuxième volet de l'intelligence
économique
comment avons nous réussi cette fois ci
est bien une veille coordonner un
travail en réseau une anticipation bien
mené et surtout articulé à une volonté
affirmée de garder un avantage
compétitif de garder en europe cet
avantage compétitif
c'est ce qui a permis de mettre en
oeuvre la stratégie de riposte à celle
de contournement qui avait été utilisée
contre sofedit ce succès a offert à
l'automobile européenne
un répit pour y arriver nous avons au
delà de ce que je viens d'expliquer du
traitement de la profusion des
informations disponibles nous avons
surtout cherché à comprendre comment le
groupe chinois analysait la situation
comment il définissait ses objectifs
comment ils déterminent est son
calendrier partir de sa vision réfléchir
et même penser comme lui pour anticiper
ses actions dans le domaine de
l'intelligence économique
l'empathie est une qualité indispensable
dans cette approche la prise en
considération de la culture de l'autre
de ce qui détermine sa façon de
raisonner et d'agir est essentielle et
quand je dis la prise en considération
c'est aussi la considération pour la
culture de l'autre
l'épisode qui suit va montrer toute
l'importance tout l'intérêt de cette
approche interculturelle
elle est française
jusqu'en 2013 j'imagine que la plupart
d'entre vous pensait qu'elle était
hollandaise elle est née en 772 de la
volonté de louis xiv et de colbert au
moment de la guerre contre les
hollandais pour remplacer les
importations des dames interdite à
partir de ce moment là et enfin elle
vient de gagner une guerre
il s'agit de la mimolette la mimolette
le plus politique de nos fromages le 8
mars 2013
la mimolette est interdite à la vente et
à l'importation aux états unis pour la
f10 est l'autorité de sécurité sanitaire
des aliments la mimolette et je lis j'ai
apporté ma tablette pourra voir les
rapports sous les yeux elle est composée
d'une substance dégoûtante putride
inadaptés comme nourriture
rien que ça le 5 juin 2014
à la veille du 70e anniversaire du
débarquement vous souvenez les chefs
d'état au château de bénouville
on leur a servi d'ailleurs de mimolette
à la veille du 70e anniversaire du
débarquement américain en normandie
l'interdiction est levée mais à la
demande des autorités américaines
aucune communication ne doit avoir lieu
sur la levée de cet embargo de 7,2 cette
interdiction et l'embargo sur la
communication ne nous en sommes
affranchis seulement hier matin lors
d'un séminaire sur l' influence qui a eu
lieu à caen en fait le véritable enjeu
de la sphère de la mimolette n'est pas
évidemment sanitaires
l'enjeu dépasse de très loin la
conformité de ce fromage à une
réglementation à une réglementation
sanitaire de 1942 que les américains
avaient exhumé pour la circonstance et
qui n'avait quasiment jamais servi
jusqu'à lors la faire c'est en réalité
nous et à la fin 2012 au moment où se
préparait le mandat de négociation de
l'union européenne sur le traité
transatlantique la france souhaitait que
les normes sanitaires ne soit pas pris
en compte dans les négociations au même
titre que l'exception culturelle
les américains quant à eux je voulais
faire tomber les barrières dressées par
l'europe contre les ogm
d'emblée le gouvernement français a
décidé d'écarter toute riposte offensive
parce qu'elle pouvoir des conséquences
très dommageables
en revanche il a voulu mener une
bataille de convictions politiques
économiques et culturelles je cite et là
on est dans l' influence et c'est très
subtil aux états unis depuis le début du
20e siècle l'hygiénisme domine c'est une
version du puritanisme qui fait que l'on
croit que les produits sains ce sont les
produits stériles
alexis carrel était passé par là lorsque
cette affaire éclate le paradigme est en
train de changer des associations
américaines sont mobilisés sur le thème
de l'étiquetage des ogm et sur le thème
de la promotion et de la défense des
produits bio est de plus en plus se
répandent dans l'opinion à partir des
milieux influents des universités de la
côte est progressivement l'idée que ce
qui est sain ce qui est bon pour la
santé ce n'est pas ce qui est stérile
mais ce qui est vivant organique bio
comme disent les américains
ce mouvement là est en train de gagner
au moment où la sphère de la mimolette
éclate
or la mimolette est un fromage vivant
c'est le motif même de son interdiction
et ce motif devient donc scandaleux
incompréhensible pour beaucoup
d'américains et les ciron ses mythes qui
perfore la croûte de la mimolette pour
lui permettre de s'aérer et bien
deviennent sympathiques aux états unis
l'opinion se mobilisent un groupe
facebook save the mimolette est créé
j'en suis membres sur facebook sur
twitter en mars 2013 plus de 40 messages
par heure sur le thème de la mimolette
le washington times lui consacre un
éditorial
free french might libérer les mythes
française
une manifestation une flash mob est
organisé sur times square à new york le
11 avril 2013 et la couverture est
mondiale on a rapatrié la mimolette
disponibles on a expliqué le directeur
génialissime 10 isigny sainte mère aux
états unis a expliqué que c'était la
dernière minute est disponible et qu'on
allait donc la distribuer gratuitement
et bien la presse mondiale était là et
le lendemain on parlait dans le monde
entier donc la mimolette n'est plus
interdite à la veille du débarquement à
la veille de l'anniversaire du
débarquement ça faisait trop tâche quand
même d'autant plus qu'ils avaient un
colloque sur le thème la liberté
ce jour-là organisée par l'american
chamber of commerce
à quand la célébrité qui est acquise aux
états unis dope la notoriété de la
mimolette vous l'avez compris l'
influence c'est la troisième composante
de l'intelligence économique et en
matière d'influencé il ne s'agit pas
d'importer directement des décisions
il s'agit plutôt de préparer le terrain
ou de s'y adapter
pour le rendre propice à l'acceptation
d'une vision c'est une stratégie
indirecte qui nécessite plus de
subtilité que de moyens elle n'est donc
pas réservé aux seuls groupes du cac 40
les qualités d'ouverture de curiosité de
remise en cause des cadre préétabli voir
d'impertinence de sensibilité à
l'interculturalité met cela à la porte
et d'entreprises de toutes tailles mais
qui sont surtout innovante est ouverte à
l'international veille protection du
patrimoine et influences telles sont les
trois composantes de l'intelligence
économique que j'ai voulu partager avec
vous aujourd'hui une question encore
pourquoi mes collègues et moi avons nous
investi du temps et notre enthousiasme
et notre énergie dans l'intelligence
économique
l'homme d'action va répondre pour
s'extraire du quotidien pour prendre de
la hauteur pour privilégier la vision la
réflexion le débat afin de redéfinir
l'action s'informer pour comprendre pour
anticiper afin d'agir efficacement
l'historien je suis de formation je suis
historien c'est un pas grand chose à
voir avec ce que j'ai fait ensuite
néanmoins ça avoir quand même un peu
l'historien dira parce que depuis
toujours je me pose une question
la question que tout historien se pose
pourquoi y at il quelque chose plutôt
que rien généralement il n'y a rien
c'est ce qu'on appelle le vide
stratégique pour ma part je préfère
trouver un sens à l'action
je vous remercie